[Música]
recuerdo allá por el año 96 me fui a
mari a vivir con mariana mi actual mujer
y lo primero que hice cuando entré al
departamento
obviamente fui abrir la heladera
mariana si no hay mayores se dulce de
leche empezamos mal
y cómo serán las cosas que si hoy venís
a mi casa no vas a encontrar ninguna de
ellas porque en mi adolescencia intensa
actividad deportiva entrenaba
regularmente un buen lomo pelito por acá
competía a nivel nacional gane algunos
trofeos pero cumplió los 17 años empezó
a doler una articulación después otra
articulación y al término de un año
dolió tanto todo el cuerpo que tuve que
abandonar todo
yo estaba cursando la carrera de
medicina tuve oportunidad de acceder a
varios especialistas llegaron un
diagnóstico el pronóstico era bastante
desfavorable y el tratamiento me
ofrecían a mí no no me convencía yo
quería saber por qué me dolía yo quería
hacer algo para estar mejor para mejorar
mi curar entender
el tema es que siguió avanzando la
enfermedad y cuando empezaron las
deformaciones articulares dije algo
tengo que hacer y me fui a buscar por
otros caminos así llegó a las medicinas
naturistas tengo una consulta con quien
fuera en ese momento mi maestro mi
mentor inmediato de la lista de
indicaciones y me voy a mi casa con la
lista indicaciones y miro el cambio más
importante era en la alimentación
miro sacar esto sacar esto sacar esto
sacar esto y en la cocina era todo lo
que yo tenía y que ahora que como eso es
lo resolvió mariana porque agarra lo
metió todo en una bolsa la mayor es el
dulce de leche también lo regaló y al
día siguiente se fue a la dietética con
la lista de las cosas que sí me
recomendaba a comer me llena la cocina
con esas bolsas quinua arroz llaman y
les estoy hablando del año 97 imagínense
lo que era mi hijo semillas frutos secos
la cara de desesperación la verdad no
sabía qué hacer no nos quedó atrás
tuvimos que aprender compramos libros
hicimos cursos quemamos algunas hojas y
después de un tiempo incorporamos a
nuestra vida una nueva manera de
alimentarnos o una intención un
aprendizaje y una repetición
incorporamos un nuevo hábito el
resultado fue que empecé a mejorar la
rigidez el entumecimiento de la mañana
había desaparecido el dolor disminuía
pude retomar el ejercicio y terminé la
carrera terminó la carrera voy a recibir
el diploma a la hermosa aula magna de la
ub en la facultad medicina
y tengo que hacer previamente el
juramento hipocrático un hipócrates que
no me habían mencionado en toda la
carrera pero sí en el curso de nutrición
naturista que yo acababa de hacer y dije
esto me interesa y me vuelco de lleno al
estudio de la alimentación natural
pero imagínense cuando entré a la
residencia yo estaba como loco a todo el
mundo no sabes lo caro que si esto tenés
que cambiar tu alimentación y te vas a
mejorar otros 5 años a mis colegas a los
pacientes fracaso total la nueva gente
no cambiaba creo que es lo que pasa me
pongo a estudiar observar dije claro lo
que pasa es que no saben cómo incorporar
estos nuevos alimentos vamos a
enseñarles y ahí fuimos a la cocina cómo
preparar un desayuno el almuerzo cómo
cocinar los cereales 5 años dando los
talleres de cocina natural
fracaso total no funcionaba yo digo si
los estoy diciendo les estoy dando la
herramienta que más quiere hacerlo
entonces dije a ver me puse a estudiar
me puse observar y me di cuenta claro la
alimentación es un hábito debemos
estudiar sobre hábitos de vida
todos el ejercicio alimentación activa
todos tan fascinado por el cambio de
hábitos y bien la importancia del cambio
de hábitos de vida para mejorar la salud
que hasta escribió un libro tu salud en
tus manos guía práctica para adquirir
hábitos de vida saludables social tomás
hacerlo acá tienes la cura patronal
entrar a una crisis yo ya no sabía cómo
ayudar a los pacientes me fui a la india
un intercambio laboral
y tuve oportunidad de ver hábitos muy
distintos a los nuestros y me puse a
observar que es un hábito cómo se genera
un hábito cómo puede ser para cambiar un
hábito y al regreso de la india a la
argentina no me pongo a dictar los
talleres de estrategias para el cambio
de hábitos dije ahora lo voy a poder
mejor o el promedio de cada 10 78
lograban cambiar sus hábitos pero había
dos o tres que no yo sé yo dije a ver
cuál es la diferencia me puse a estudiar
y observar cuál es la diferencia porque
él puede y el otro no y me di cuenta que
existe una fuerza que es la fuerza de
voluntad
y ahí me metí que es la fuerza de
voluntad como si es como sé dónde está
lamentablemente les cuento a la fuerza
de voluntad no la pueden comprar en
cajitas de 30 comprimidos en la farmacia
pero existen ejercicios que desee
tranquilos uno puede así como voy al
gimnasio y entreno los músculos puedo
entrenar la fuerza de voluntad
pero bueno vamos a ver qué es un hábito
y para que lo vivan vamos a hacer un
pequeño ejercicio crucense todos de
brazos algunos ya están crucense de
brazos
bien tan cómodos la está pasando bien
ahora pongan de nuevo las manos sobre
las piernas y ahora va a ver un pequeño
cambio se van a cruzar de brazos pero
con los brazos al revés invertidos
algunos les cuestan más otros menos
pudieron que es en esa posición
ustedes perciben en este momento cierta
sensación de incomodidad
eso es porque usted están habituados a
cruzarse de brazos de determinada manera
cómo se define un hábito un hábito es
una actividad que una vez aprendida y
repetida varias veces lo logra
realizarse sin dificultad y de manera
automática si usted es la primera vez
que manejaron están totalmente
concentrados en el manejo pero hoy
pueden ir manejando automáticamente
mientras charlan con el que tienen al
lado
qué es lo que pasa en nuestro cerebro
a medida que yo repito una acción las
áreas cerebrales involucradas en la
realización de ese acto van
desarrollando sinapsis nuevas conexiones
neuronales circuitos que van entre el
cerebro y el cuerpo autopistas de manera
tal que después de repetirlo varias
veces yo puedo realizar la acción fácil
y eficientemente
lo que pasa y lo que quiero resaltar es
que
yo soy el que decide la acción yo soy el
que con mi voluntad y mi querer le exijo
al cerebro el cerebro se adapta para que
yo pueda realizar mi voluntad y lo que
yo quiero porque resaltó esto porque hoy
todavía desde las neurociencias se
plantea que determinado cambio en un
núcleo o en la corteza frontal le ha
otorgado nuevas habilidades al ser
humano y éste evoluciona y es justamente
al revés él es un órgano más que está a
nuestro servicio sí mucho más complejo
pero está a mi servicio para que yo
pueda realizar mi voluntad
existe evidencia científica de lo que
digo pero lamentablemente todavía se
piensa y están ambos anclados en el
viejo paradigma mecanicista el paradigma
del hombre máquina
pero sugiero que comencemos a apurarnos
un poquito en los estudios científicos
porque el paradigma mecanicista no nos
está llevando un buen puerto
como logró generar un nuevo hábito tres
pasos dos misiones del principio
intención aprendizaje y repetición
intención de cambio realmente yo quiero
cambiar
veamos una conversación muy frecuente en
el consultorio no tenemos a jose 62 años
hipertenso diabético colesterol alto
medicado para las tres cosas índice de
masa corporal obesidad grado 2 y una
circunferencia abdominal de 120
centímetros que el porte orgulloso el
domingo cuando llega el asado
ahora la historia clínica jose que lo
trae por acá a mí y si somos dos acá nos
así agua a mí a mí me cuando mi mujer
si estás terminó la consulta si
terminamos vamos a tomar unos mates jose
y la semana que viene venga tu mujer
porque si le digo cualquier cambio que
sea de manera impuesta será embarcarse
en un camino de sufrimiento inútil la
toma de conciencia es un paso
fundamental para el cambio es ese
momento en el que yo con todas las
células de mi cuerpo y una convicción
firme
quiero cambiar como estoy haciendo las
cosas y dirigir mi vida hacia otro lado
después va a quedar una vez que me
convencí va a quedar aprender en esta
segunda instancia es bueno hacer cursos
apoyarse en la familia apoyarse en los
amigos hasta que lo repito varias veces
y se incorpora el hábito
vamos a ver un ejemplo de un hábito con
el que me consultan frecuentemente es
muy difícil de cambiar es algo que se da
a lohan a lo largo ya lo ancho de
nuestra hermosa argentina y es casi un
ritual
10 de la mañana más o menos pusieron la
paga para unos mates un café y que hay
tu compañero de trabajo pone sobre la
mesa unas medias lunas de manteca el
aroma nomás ya te hace agua la boca
y vos decís este me lo hace a propósito
y ahí está lo abre en el paquete y ahí
está ella
empieza la policía brillan esplende te
llama casi vistes y vos te habías
recontra prometido que el lunes empezaba
la dieta
pero las facturas más fuertes
por eso por qué ocurre esto porque el
hábito activa el sistema límbico y
produce secreción de dopamina y
serotonina qué significa esto en triollo
que pone una harina se va queda un
espacio vacío
sí
por eso por eso es clave incorporar es
muy recomendable incorporar un nuevo
hábito que active mi circuito de
satisfacción y recompensa sí pero tengan
cuidado con que hábito van a elegir
porque media luna de manteca mata
galleta de arroz
bueno esto les quería contar fue en el
volcán lanín
yo ya llevaba para este momento 20 años
de a peter no mató idea un primer
intento fallido por congelamiento en
tres dedos y muy mal clima tuvimos que
bajar estando a sólo 600 metros de la
cumbre
un segundo intento no me alcanzó golpe
un segundo intento
una mochila de 21 kilos 3 de la mañana
15 grados bajo cero poniéndote los
crampones es el momento en el que vos
decís quién me mandó a meterme en esta
y ahí aparece algo que desde adentro
fuertemente te impulsa a seguir
después las satisfacciones los premios
y la satisfacción de alcanzar la meta
que nos había propuesto
existe una fuerza dentro de cada uno de
todos ustedes que se llama fuerza de
voluntad y esta fuerza es exclusiva del
ser humano
al observar el reino animal yo no
encuentro esta fuerza una vaca no se
plantea cómo puedo hacer para ser una
mejor vaca en el futuro
un perro no dice voy a entrenar todos
los días a parecer el perro más rápido
del barrio el perro corre juega come si
se puede acostar como de un lugar para
dormir lo va a hacer y él está contento
con eso él es un perro él es un perro
en cambio el ser humano
es el único que voluntariamente puede
salir de la zona de confort y a pesar de
las dificultades superar obstáculos
perseverar en pude alcanzar una meta
propuesta
ir superándose a sí mismo
entonces si yo quiero cambiar mi vida y
mis hábitos lo primero que debo hacer es
tomar conciencia quién soy
dónde estoy que quiero en mi vida hacia
dónde la quiero llevar
de esta manera el cambio deja de ser una
tortura para convertirse en un deseo y
ese deseo va a poner en marcha ese
poderoso motor que es la fuerza de
voluntad
en el ejercicio
de esta fuerza vamos a ir conduciendo
conscientemente nuestra vida hacia donde
nosotros queremos vamos a ir
manifestándonos a través de nuestras
acciones y de esta manera lograremos ser
la mejor versión de nosotros mismos
ya muchas gracias
[Aplausos]